bonsoir françois gentili merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france pour
évoquer ce dossier est ce qu on peut
désormais parler d'une situation apaisée
mais finalement loin d'être réglée au
karabagh alors il est vrai il est vrai
que les armes se sont tues mais sur le
terrain la situation est train d'être
satisfaisante puisque si l'arménie a
récupéré son corridor en effet par
lequel il y avait la jonction avec le
haut karabakh est par contre des
territoires qui ont été amputés haut
karabakh est en effet on a fait état de
17 ans de malversations de comportement
est mise en danger du patrimoine je
pense que ce qu'il faut déplorer c'est
bien sûr que cette question n'ait pas
été réglée avant donc cours d'un cadre
du groupe de contact de mise contre la
russie les etats-unis et la france avec
l'azerbaïdjan l'arménie la turquie
et quand on roule s'accorde pas en effet
pour une solution durable c'est à dire
que si l'azerbaïdjan ce recouvre en
effet ces territoires perdus en 1992 94
lorsqu'il était dans une logique il faut
pas non plus amputé le haut karabakh
comme c'est fait aujourd'hui et contre
l'intégrité territoriale retrouvait de
l'azerbaïdjan il faut en effet
reconnaître le caractère manière du haut
karabakh est également le faire venir à
ses frontières internes tels que c'est
avant mais il faut avouer que l'on gère
en conséquence ici un prochain projet un
programme qui est quelque peu insoluble
c'est en effet la 7e ce mécano
diabolique avait été mis en place ou non
ceux des tic notamment avec staline
c'est un enchevêtrement des peuples et
tout ça ne peut être gérée que par
négociation et le moins possible bien
sûr et pas peut-être par par un conflit
pour vous ce n'est donc pas une affaire
terminée
c'est un conflit qui peut ré exploser à
tout moment
aujourd'hui concrètement parce que en
effet on a vu l'azerbaïdjan avait pris
le dessus il ya une mutation stratégique
depuis 25 ans qui est très importante
c'est que là vous savez il ya deux
hommes essentiel c'est un choix
politique c'est le les tendances
démographiques et la puissance de feu et
il faut le constater l'arménie a perdu
sur ces deux plans elle a décroché au
plan démographique puisque aujourd'hui
pour à un arménien il ya 3 il ya 3 3 à 0
et sur le plan de l'armement en effet
l'azerbaïdjan a développé une politique
de puissance tous azimuts ayant déjà
fourni par la russie par israël en
conséquence et puis on sait bien sur
l'apport aujourd'hui la puissance qu'on
peut appeler la puissance tutélaire turc
puisque les azéris ont sont perçues
comme un prolongement de la historique
delà de la nation turque probante aux
pentes urania et là on peut penser que
la situation est figée pour de bon sens
pau un certain nombre de temps au profit
de l'azerbaïdjan à sa terre qu'elle
s'était figé pour 25 ans au final le
dollar manille mais aujourd'hui le le
contexte géopolitique c'est totalement
retourné alors j'ai seulement la
communauté internationale comme la
france un voudrait que le rôle de la
turquie soit précisée ça vous semble
être une priorité à vous aussi si le
rôle de la turquie doit de préciser il
faut que la turquie soit une table de
négociation avec les autres et qu'elle
joue un rôle d'une puissance qui est
qu'il est aussi ses terres que en effet
la solution c'est que que l'azerbaïdjan
est retrouvé sur l'intégrité
territoriale et est un fait mais que le
nagorny karabakh voit en effet son
caractère à amelia affirmé puis c'est
une population un territoire qui a
toujours était arménien et aujourd'hui
même le haut karabakh est amputé d'un
certain nombre de ces partis donc il
faut revenir sur le conte peut appeler
en cassant le droit international
même si sage cette frontière interne
avec l'intégrité la serva de gens mais
aussi l'intégrité du du haut karabakh et
qu'ils devraient être
mon sens une seule une solution
équilibrée sur le terrain avec une
garantie sur le terrain aujourd'hui
effectués par la turquie et la russie ne
voit pas d'autres pays en train de de
s'impliquer puisque le lait la france a
été a été absente depuis le depuis le
début et les états unis en plan en
pleine campagne et oriane carole alors
que avec la france les etats-unis la
russie et copréside le groupe de contact
de mise sur le haut-karabagh mis en
place depuis un quart de siècle
ils n'ont pas du tout été en mesure
d'agir en tout cas effectivement les
russes sont seuls sur place désormais il
assure la force au niveau de la paix
mais aussi l'équipement de missions
humanitaires notamment est un avion
cargo d'ailleurs qui amenait des
équipements il ya deux jours c'est une
mission compliquée oui c'est une mission
compliquée puisque il dit
non seulement l'humanitaire mais
également un afflux très important de
réfugiés vers vers l'arménie proprement
dites 1a s'attendent de population d'une
haut-karabakh voyant leur leur
territoire des hommes est sous tutelle
hazard badiadji au passage en plus on ne
sait pas quel sera le sort juridique du
haut-karabakh puisque c'était un un
territoire je rappelle autonome arménien
autonome au sein de l'azerbaïdjan est
alors que ce territoire qui a terminé un
doit avoir également son statut
définitif est précisée pour la sécurité
de sa population est ce qu'on va
parisien dépendre achement l'armée lee
d'autonomie ça il va falloir très vite
tracer les contours juridiques du
haut-karabakh respecte également les
frontières telles qu est qu elle avait
été là c'est difficile parce que c'est
le fait militaire qui a parlé au delà du
fait juridique et et géographique en
effet la vida du mali terré et est
aujourd'hui qu'il est compliqué parce
que il y à des réfugiés et que
aujourd'hui en effet la russie et cei de
martyrs ces populations arméniennes sur
place mais celle ci en effet saisi d'un
certain effroi honte ans à affluer
massivement vers alain maignan c'est
qu'erevan aujourd'hui à kayes plusieurs
centaines de milliers de réfugiés du
haut karabakh
merci à vous françois constantini
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france